vamos
hoy es un día intenso
estas cajas llenas de ayuda irán hacia
harkov ucrania
violen a una joven ucraniana ha venido a
ayudar
elena vive en antalya en el sur de
turquía donde rusos y ucranianos hacen
vida como vecinos sin embargo la guerra
ha hecho que muchos rompan relaciones en
esta ciudad
se estima que en antalya habitan 28 mil
rusos y cerca de 10 mil ucranianos olga
de nacionalidad rusa quien aún mantiene
contacto con sus amigas ucranianas
lamenta lo que su gobierno le está
haciendo a ucrania
vergüenza es mi país mi gente
pero si me avergüenza el presidente de
mi gobierno y si siento miedo por mi
futuro
y
desde que comenzó la invasión a olena
sale poco de casa por el miedo y el
estrés sin embargo ha decidido visitar a
su amiga nastase a quien trabaja con
siendo vestidos y banderas día y noche
para poder enviar dinero a su familia en
ucrania ella es el único sustento
económico que les queda
para mí lo más importante es que mi
familia aún está viva pero por supuesto
que cada vez que voy a dormir pienso que
les puede ocurrir algo es muy difícil me
afecta mucho emocionalmente y
físicamente no es fácil estando tan
lejos sin poder hacer nada es verdad que
no no
anastasia como muchos otros ucranianos
tiene familia en rusia pese a ello
perdonar y sanar las heridas que provoca
esta guerra dice le costará muchos años